Shelby was doing stuff that no one else
was even trying and a lot of people to
even realize he was a baby in the late
2016 is like everything has already been
done you know at that point the scene
shifted to the sub six month old group
tons of time out but Shelby next level
he feels like leaving drill streets
across the high alpine training on point
he's died from points the guy had a
fourteen behind him first went was a
giggle horn first instead of the diapers
feel Murphy the Blum picking him up one
after the next
Bam Bam Bam the guy had goals with focus
if he wants to see this like the first
six month old to solo the nipple route
I'm now trundle it's looking like he's
going to do it and then Ricky came along
Ricky came out of nowhere she's taking
off all of Shelby's route
Bam Bam Bam one after the next just
taken him down it him look like he's
like crawling backwards and then word
spread Rick I want the nipple route can
you imagine a more epic contest two
Titans at the top of their game like
little Titan there's a mad rush to get
their base camp together you know with
any of these highly technical sense
you're up against weather so the both
the best camp and this huge guts to win
rolls in just blow Shelby's ten away and
he's just uh just stranded yeah he's got
like a couple diapers in a white and
Rick is close by piles of white
piles of ices Shelby makes the hard
decision he's gonna have to seek refuge
and he also needs typers
some say it was a little bit fast rule
whatever it was it was beautiful and
like that they don't care about money
anymore why do we climb mountain hmm you
know what I think we climb mountains for
adventure for challenge to find
ourselves but at the end of the day it's
about finding each other and that is
what matters most
[Music]
[Music]